there were three features three features
that I asked for you to include on the
graphs what were the three features okay
number one intercepts number two
asymptotes and number three a point the
scale okay now let me just mention a
couple of things about this um I got
asked the question like what's the
difference we sketch and draw or graph
or illustrator or whatever hood they
have they're my short answer to that
question is the difference they ask you
to draw it you put on as much detail as
you can and in this case like these are
the important things that you need in
order to be able to determine this is
the graph that has been asked for and
it's not some other graph that looks
similar but might be slightly different
for instance without being too spoilery
I think you can see the graph wanna
graph for a more-or-less going to have
the same shape they'll have the same
intercept but have the same asymptote
right so if that's all I put on there
you won't be able to tell which graph is
which and that's why we have a point to
scale because that helps you distinguish
okay so these kinds of a life it's not
an arbitrary list of things that we want
you to put on there these are the things
that if you don't have all of them I
don't really know if you can accurately
draw this graph right so these are the
things that will help me understand if
you know what you're doing so let's
start doing this now this is just our
basic flow graph okay now we're familiar
with the basic shape okay but now we
need to stop putting on the information
okay so for example in order intercepts
is only one there's an x intercept which
is one one excellent okay just like the
y intercept is the corresponding
exponential would also be one there's an
asymptote it's always gonna be when I
said what is it in this case X is equal
to zero
and you should label it as such now I'm
almost done my point for scale here okay
now the easiest way I think you can do
this is that like some students I've
seen they'll say oh okay well that's one
and so I'll put one up here and then
I'll mark across now that's going to
cause you some problems okay because one
of the most important things about scale
is that your axes can be different to
each other but they can't be different
to themselves right so see how I put an
intercept on three all right now that
I've locked that in this distance on the
x axis this distance must be one it must
always be one wherever I am on the graph
right so therefore the way that I would
approach this is I would say I'll draw
my okay right
a nice convenient point and you really
can pick any point you like right think
easy values rather than hard those an
easy one would be 2 right because I'm in
base 2
if I were in base 3 I choose 3 now now
that that distance is correct once I Mak
that up to the corresponding point up
there wherever that equals to wherever
that equals to I know what that value is
going to be it's log base 2 of 2 which
is okay now as it just so happens
because I'm such an important graph HUF
right the one on the y axis pretty much
matches the one on the x axis but it
doesn't need to it doesn't need to it
can be much higher it could be much
lower it doesn't matter as long as this
is consistent and at a point okay and
you do have a choice by the way you can
see the way I've I've Illustrated like I
put that point on there I'll show you
why so you can see where it is
alternatively
sorry too common one that unambiguously
tells you where that point is but sees
you have to measure from the answers I
kind of think you're saving yourself
time just by doing other ones okay but
either miss now just before I leave off
this very first example I will mention
okay in some cases [ __ ] accuse you got
further into like extension to that I
think sometimes you will be provided
access to drawn okay but you might think
they're trying to give you a hand
sorta are but they're also making things
harder for you because if they provide
for you a set of axes right almost
certainly that set of axes will come
prepackaged with a scale right and there
will be numbers there that are defined
for you right now once they have defined
it you're locked into using them and you
must be consistent with them and you
have to be consistent all the way right
so not only do I have you know this
point over here which is the intercept
I'm going to have for instance this two
one
okay but as a marker once I see this
scale I'm gonna look for a third point
straight away have a look at the scale
I've got here I'm gonna go for and
that's gonna have to match up to two
okay now if you do the way I oppression
you just go you just read right almost
certainly you know you're just like this
which looks like a log graph doesn't it
but it's not to scale on this set of
axes okay so in those cases where you do
get given a set of axes watch out for
them they'll come with numbers and
you've got to use them right so just
just plot a few and then just draw your
no no don't do that cuz they're just
said to scale right so if you can say
not scale or you can have yeah no
unfortunately you have to say okay
you're happy with that now that was just
the first one so the next we'll proceed
rather more quickly okay um here I have
what kind of shift it's a vertical shift
it's going up isn't it
so being that my very question tip is
here if I shift that vertical asymptotes
up it's just gonna stay where it is okay
so my asymptotes in the same spot okay
but how do you moved up like you can
imagine as I move this up the entity
that is gonna move in closer towards the
y-axis right how much closer is it going
to move well how do you usually work out
x-intercepts we let y y0 right so if I
do that in this case I'm just growing on
the color you can see it's not that hard
to work this out if Y is equal to zero
then log to base sorry log base two of X
equals minus one just keep that one of
the other side right so now when you
convert this back into an index equation
where to go from this becomes zero and
that one robot okay
so this really means X is as soon as the
minus 1 which is 1/2 right so actually
as I draw my graph again that's gonna be
a part now that's a huh so I'm this
ordering closer I need a point to scale
what would you suggest if I put in if I
put in now careful because if that's 1/2
and 1 must be exactly twice as far away
from the axis what is going to be the
corresponding value
yes a log base 2 of 1 so what power do I
have to raise 2 to to get one of the
answer is 0 0 plus 1 so this is gonna
map across to 1 ok you happy with that
and let's put our equation on there and
then we okay X